[Musique]
dans le contexte international actuel
avec une augmentation de la
conflictualité et avec le conflit
ukrainien l'ensemble des questions de
défense sont sur le devant de la scène
depuis le 24 février et le début de ce
conflit tragique en ukraine l'ensemble
des états membres et la france se pose
la question de l'évolution des moyens
attribués à la défense
beaucoup de programmes qui doivent se
faire en coopération entre la france et
d'autres pays européens sur les nouveaux
matériels et il y a évidemment des
atouts français sur du matériel
extrêmement compétitif avec toutes les
difficultés qu'on connaît la capacité
d'exportation capacité de convaincre un
certain nombre de nos voisins de faire
le choix de matériel européen il ya
beaucoup de défis devant nous il ya une
impérieuse nécessité de construire une
europe industriels de la défense pour
pouvoir être souverain sur bien des
points mais malheureusement sur cette
question il ya encore beaucoup de gens à
convaincre et ça n'est pas simple du
tout
on souhaitait faire escale au stand du
ministère de la défense ukrainienne où
il y avait et le ministre et le vice
ministre de la défense nous avons eu un
long entretien à l'ong échanges à la
fois pour les assurer de notre
solidarité de notre soutien de notre
admiration et aussi pour prendre la
mesure des équipements que les
ukrainiens attendait pour se défendre
face à l'agression russe et donc nous
avons un certain nombre de précisions
mais l'idée c'est de dire aux ukrainiens
la france est à vos côtés je pense que
c'est le message que moi-même
accompagnant le président larcher je
porterai le 7 juillet prochain lorsque
nous sommes inquiets